yesterday I told you with all the normal
disclaimers and caveats that a new CNN
poll has Donald Trump down by a historic
14 points to Joe Biden in national
presidential election polling 55 to 41
now this is important not just because
the 14 point lead is unconscionable but
it's also important because a challenger
hitting 50% so regularly five months
before the election is not very common
Donald Trump has had an absolutely wild
tantrum in response and I want to give
you a look at what he said and then we
can fact check it so Trump has been
reportedly going nuts on his campaign
manager Brad parse scale how could I be
losing to Biden how could these polls be
true we talked yesterday about this zoom
call during which Corey Lewandowski
asked what exactly is our message for
re-election in November and this all led
to Donald Trump having a tantrum
tweeting quote CNN polls are as fake as
their reporting same numbers and worse
against crooked Hillary Dems would
destroy America so there are two
empirical claims being made there the
first is CNN's polling is bad Trump
calls it fake the second is that his
numbers were even worse against Hillary
in 2016 than they are today against
Biden and yet he still managed to win in
2016 so this is a great opportunity to
just examine empirical claims first is
CNN a good pollster or a bad pollster
remember the polling arms of a lot of
these media outlets are separate from
the reporting or broadcast arm so for
example Fox News polling is actually
quite good despite Fox News Channel
being a right-wing hack job CNN polls
are also well ranked they're ranked B+
by 538 so CNN polling is quite good
Trump's claim that cNN polling is bad is
incorrect second claim from Trump is
that he was polling even worse against
Hillary in 2016 and he's still won
that's simply not true if we go back and
look at June
of 2016 meaning five months before the
2016 election just as right now were
five months out you can see if you're
watching that the with the exception of
one or two outliers Hillary Clinton was
more or less polling four points ahead
of Trump and reminder she did win the
popular vote against Trump by a couple
of points if you look at the polling of
Trump versus Hillary right before the
election you can see it was even closer
Hillary was ahead by three point two on
Election Day and she won by two point
one because remember these are popular
vote polls so Trump is wrong on both
counts
he's losing to Biden now by more than he
was losing to Hillary and CNN is a
pretty good pollster but it doesn't
really matter because this is all
narrative it's what can you tell your
supporters that will get them fired up
and fake News CNN is lying to you gets
his supporters fired up last thing Trump
then tweeted that he has hired a
pollster to debunk the CNN poll because
he was clearly so triggered by it
tweeting I have retained highly
respected pollster mcLaughlin and
associates to analyze today's CNN poll
and others which I felt were fake based
on the incredible enthusiasm we are
receiving read analysis for yourself
this is the same thing they and others
did when we defeat defeated crooked
Hillary in 2016 they are called
suppression polls and are out to dampen
enthusiasm despite three and a half
years of phony witch hunts we are
winning and we will close it out on
November 3rd again the letter Trump
posted with this analysis is all wrong
the McLaughlin memo wrongly states that
the CNN poll finding Biden up 14 is from
an all adults sample that's not true CNN
says very clearly in the methodology it
is a registered voter sample so even the
analysis of the poll that Trump paid for
is bogus so the final message this
election is nowhere near over this is
going to be a fight every voter should
assume from can win their state and you
should operate on that basis this is a
big gap so
certainly Trump will number one need a
credible story as to here's how I am
fixing the economy here is how I am
dealing with the coronavirus well
because otherwise he's not going to be
able to turn it around so expect that
story to be told it'll probably be a
story of rehabilitation of the American
economy and number two Biden probably
needs to mess up at this point um in
order to squander the lead but both of
those things can happen we can't be
complacent we all have a role to play
let me know what you think I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman we are in the middle
of a global hundred year pandemic the
highest unemployment since 1948 which is
the first year that unemployment was
tracked under the modern system the
largest nationwide protests that we've
seen in a very long time these over
police brutality and one of the highest
numbers of horrifying police brutality
incidents that this country has seen in
such a short period of time in decades
and Donald Trump set a new record for
himself sending out 200 tweets and
retweets in a single day on Friday the
president cannot lead and instead he's
tweeting from behind his bunker fact
base which track this tweeted we're
wrapping the day at 200 tweets for
Donald Trump most for the account ever
period at 468 tweets it's the most in a
week for Trump during his presidency and
74 tweets between 8:00 and 9:00 a.m. the
most in an hour ever as you can see
there if you're looking at the chart
along with me June 5th surpassing
January 22nd with 200 total tweets and
retweets the most of any data in Donald
Trump's presidency Donald Trump is now
tweeting by the way from behind two
miles of fencing and barricades much of
it installed over the last week as
bunker boy as many are calling him
further isolates himself from reality so
there are about five or six
different relevant layers here first of
all I'm not President of the United
States I just have this show I don't
have time to tweet nearly 200 times in a
day on a day where I tweet a lot where I
feel like I probably tweeted too much
today I might tweet 15 times maybe if I
do a bunch of retweets maybe 20 times
and and I'm not president of the United
States that's the first story secondly
this day Friday included 74 tweets in an
hour between 8 and 9 a.m. Eastern Time
that is more than a tweet per hour a
tweet per minute for an entire hour that
is an unhealthy level of social media
use which raises further questions on
its own number three again we're in the
middle of a global hundred year pandemic
highest unemployment since 1948 a huge
nationwide protests huge police
brutality issues and Donald Trump sets a
record for himself
tweeting and retweeting 200 times in a
single day that doesn't make sense we
need a leader who can lead and do things
now some of you will say well Trump
can't lead so we're better off with him
just sitting around tweeting but the
tweets are actually doing damage it's
not like the tweets are neutral he's
still doing damage by tweeting number
four Trump just got done attacking
Twitter and he's using it more than ever
why not get away from Twitter if Twitter
is treating him so terribly because he
simply can't and that gets us to the
clinical aspects of this I spoke to a
couple of mental health professionals
over the weekend and they all had a
similar version of the same thing to say
which is essentially that Donald Trump's
behavior as we now see it on Twitter is
compulsive and obsessive and it's a sort
of decompensation of sorts his behavior
is the type of behavior that you know if
your coworker at BestBuy is behaving
this way if your coworker at an
accounting firm is behaving this way
you'd probably go and talk to HR and say
something's not right here
it's manic behavior it's compulsive
behavior you might have some kind of an
intervention there might be a
psychiatric evaluation done at a certain
point that's the type of behavior that
were
seeing from Donald Trump now one last
thing you might have noticed that I
didn't go through and read individual
tweets of Donald Trump during this
segment and there's no shortage of
tweets that I could have read we are
passed the significance of any one of
Donald Trump's tweets in general now if
Donald Trump tweets something that
specifically newsworthy or actionable if
it relates to some new policy that his
administration is going to be rolling
out if it's a direct attack on an ally
if there's some kind of particular
relevance I will tell you what the
content of Trump's tweets is but what
happened on Friday 200 tweets and
retweets
it's just erratic behavior and I don't
want to glorify or lend credence to any
one message that Trump sent by actually
reading the tweets you know it was a
combination of lies and smears and
attacks and bragging self-congratulation
retweeting right-wing trash and
conspiracy theories that's what it was
that's the summary the individual tweets
really were irrelevant they didn't
communicate any particular policy they
were mostly smears of other people so I
am NOT going to give them more
credibility or attention than they need
other than to point out 200 tweets in a
day is bonkers and this is the President
of the United States that is where we
will leave it and certainly if Trump
does actually tweet something relevant
to policy I will tell you what it is
fear not in a stunning new poll
Republican Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell is losing to challenger Amy
McGrath in his Kentucky Senate
re-election race now I'll give you the
caveats in a moment but the fact that
this is even close is already a really
big deal it's typically not close at all
in Kentucky for Mitch McConnell in his
re-elections there's a new poll from our
mg group and it has Amy McGrath up 41
240mm agree as you may know is an Air
Force veteran and challenging one of the
one of the longest sitting senators and
the longest ever tenured senator out of
Kentucky now what's very very
interesting is that the poll
4140 in favor of Amy McGrath it's within
the margin of error a statistical tie
certainly when people participating in
the poll are told Amy McGrath favors
congressional term limits and Mitch
McConnell opposes them which is true her
support actually increases pretty
dramatically but there are a lot of
undecided still in this poll and there
are certainly a fair number of people
supporting someone other than Mitch
McConnell or Amy McGrath so when we
typically talk about the Senate in 2020
and we think about what's the most
likely path that Democrats could have to
take in control of the Senate in 2020 we
often go to Arizona where Mark Kelly is
very much ahead of martha mcsalley the
incumbent republican will look at Cory
Gardner Republican incumbent in Colorado
who is well behind and may lose we think
about Susan Collins in Maine Tom Tillis
in North Carolina maybe Steve Bullock in
Montana there's a few others I'm not
talking about all of them but we don't
usually talk about Mitch McConnell Mitch
McConnell has been one of the most
effective Republican legislators in
years he's gotten a ton of right-wing
judges confirmed he's successfully
blocked Barack Obama Supreme Court pick
Merrick garland holding that seat open
for a year
until Donald Trump was inaugurated and
ultimately selected Neil Gorsuch that is
horrifying horrifying but if you are a
Republican that's a major accomplishment
and that should have been Barack Obama's
selection and Mitch McConnell was able
to hold it for Donald Trump disgusting
but if you're on their side you love it
it would be incredible to remove Mitch
McConnell and he's currently down one
now let me give you the caveat Mitch
McConnell is down one but it's 41 to 40
so statistically it's a tie and the
Challenger at some point is going to
need to get to 50% or close to it
Amy McGrath is at 41 if she can't start
getting to 45 48 closer to 50 typically
in these elections the undecideds and
the third party holdouts
as we get closer to Election Day are
going to break for the incumbent in this
case it's Mitch McConnell so Amy McGrath
ceiling could be the 41
that she has right now which is not
going to be enough to win it but it's a
fight it's a fight anti McConnell
Kentuckians should get involved in this
race it would be a race if you're in a
state that doesn't have a hotly
contested Senate seat you could get
involved in phone banking and
fundraising for Amy McGrath McConnell
has been in the US Senate longer than
any other senator from Kentucky has ever
been Mitch McConnell went to the Senate
in 1985 the year after I was born Mitch
McConnell went to the Senate and Mitch
McConnell is still in the Senate it's
too much it's too much he's got to go
he's been a Senate Majority Leader for
five years since 2015 and he has left a
massive destruction in his wake and if
indeed Mitch McConnell loses it would be
a huge bellwether for how the entire
Senate is going that usually when we do
analyses we say here's how this one race
is going here's how this other race is
going the reality is that these things
come in waves if the incumbent from 1985
Republican majority leader is knocked
out in Kentucky a lot of these other
races are likely to go in the direction
of Democrats and we will probably if
that happens have Donald Trump to thank
seats and states that are rarely if ever
in play for Democrats are now a fight
even forcing Republicans to have to
spend money to defend them is a victory
because these are often very easy to win
states and races for Republicans so pick
a race if it's in your state great if
you're in a state without a close
election find something nearby or
something you're interested in there is
plenty to be done and this being
Kentucky I'm thinking about getting a
nice bottle of Kentucky bourbon to have
for election night coverage and if Mitch
McConnell loses on November 3rd maybe
we'll open that up even though it will
be a very big uphill battle but by the
way the the warning is because this
polling is closed this piggybacks on the
earlier story about the suppression we
saw yesterday in Georgia because this
election is closed we should expect that
Kentucky Republicans are going to go
extra hard on the voter suppression and
the other types of election fraud
tactics so we will likely need extra
margin if Amy McGrath is to defeat Mitch
McConnell it's been happening this week
in Georgia and elsewhere massive poll
closures creating very large
weights and disproportionately
democratic areas we know the tactics but
we've got to fight them okay next week
Tuesday night 8 p.m. Eastern we will be
having the second David Pakman show
chess tournament this is free to all
this is not Members Only there's no fee
this is just free it's just building
sportsmanship and camaraderie in a
difficult time so that'll be Tuesday
June 16th at 8 p.m. Eastern the
tournament will be on Leach s org I'll
have more info about that but put it in
your calendar I hope you'll play we had
500 players last time and I hope we do
better than that in the meantime make
sure to let me know what you think about
this McConnell race on Twitter I am deep
hackman on twitter so Donald Trump just
got his worst polling during this
campaign so far down to Joe Biden by 14
points nationally and these are just
unconscionable numbers and a report from
Axios about what's going on inside the
Trump White House and inside the Trump
campaign shows panic fear anger at
what's going on so this latest poll from
CNN CNN is rated as a B+ pollster by 538
their polling is pretty good
they have Trump's approval down to 38%
that rivals the lows of Trump's
presidency and then in terms of Biden
versus Trump for November this poll has
Biden at 55 Trump at 41 now what's
important about this poll other than
Biden's absolutely ridiculous 14-point
lead is that Biden is well above 50% if
you look back to June of 2016 in other
words this time in the 2016 election
Hillary Clinton was very rarely hitting
50% you can go back and you can find a
poll here or there where Hillary had 50
maybe 51 but in June of 2016 Hillary
Clinton was mostly polling in the low
40s and occasionally in the high 40s
with the occasional 50 or 51 Joe Biden
is now regularly polling at 50% and or
more in recent polls and that is a very
different starting point
then we're Hillary Clinton was back in
June of 2016 now the differences Biden's
running against an incumbent
whereas Hillary Clinton running against
Trump was two challengers or two
potential candidates and there is some
degree to which one might expect as we
get closer to the election people will
break for the incumbent and that would
certainly benefit Donald Trump so
publicly Trump is insisting that he's
doing really well he very often will
tweet versions of what he tweeted this
morning this morning saying quote
ninety-six percent approval rating in
the Republican Party thank you
the source is never cited the source is
never clear but Trump posts that all the
time and publicly he's pretending that
he's doing really well and that Joe
Biden can't win unless you know
Democrats cheat in the fall or something
like that which is hilarious by the way
privately Donald Trump's aides and
advisors are coming to him and telling
him these polls don't look good and you
need to do something they know how bad
the polls are a source briefed on
internal polls is calling them quote
brutal and seeing a major drop-off in
independent support while Trump's
Republican support is remaining
relatively high his Democratic support
is extremely low independents have been
shifting away from Trump significantly
in the last few months the of when the
looting starts the shooting starts thing
that Trump said is troubling for some of
Donald Trump's top aides and clearly
they know that Trump's disgustingly
divisive reaction to the protests have
heard him and they are saying Trump
needs to instead give a message of hope
optimism and unification and from that
recommendation came this idea that's now
being floated about maybe Trump could
give a quote major speech on race now I
have to tell you as hilarious as a major
speech on race would be from Donald
Trump I don't even know that I would
cover it normally I would you know
stream major presidential speeches but I
don't know that I would cover that it
would be merely a propaganda piece Trump
probably would barely even understand
what he was reading off of his prompter
it would be calculated to try to get a
few more points in a poll and I don't
even know that I would cover that speech
now a few insights into a zoom call that
took place with Trump's top campaign
advisers Corey Lewandowski asked the
question what is our message which is a
relevant question it's not clear what
Trump's message is right now they seem
to settle on the idea of something like
a great American comeback theme the idea
of using those misreported jobs numbers
from last week to build this optimistic
comeback strategy for the next five
months that's going to be tough because
Donald Trump on one hand is appealing to
his hardcore base with his wild and
hateful and divisive rhetoric talking
about sending in the military ominous
weapons that doesn't play well with a
lot of people but if Trump switches to a
unification message to try to get his
polling up it's not clear that that's
going to play well with his hardcore
supporters what would be nice would be
for Trump to say hey you know what guys
we failed we failed the country has lost
confidence in me if they ever had it we
are all going to be resigning we failed
we are failures and I'm sorry that's
what should happen it will never happen
they are going to have to be removed
when you get a tick and it attaches to
your body and you try to just pull it
off you can't the tick hangs on for dear
life they are going to have to be
removed like a deer tick you're gonna
have to pour alcohol on it take tweezers
squeeze it by the head and try to get it
to release its grip on your skin that's
the analogy of how they're going to have
to be removed these are some of trumps
best worst numbers ever but at the same
time 38% of the country thinks he's
doing a good job that is horrifying and
it means he can win in November and I
don't know if the 38% are people who are
cult-like in their following of Trump or
what he does doesn't matter or they're
not paying attention or they don't care
or they're cognitively impaired I don't
know what it is but he still has 38%
support he can still win and we need to
get out there and make sure that we
prevent the re-election in November one
of the police officers charged in the
killing of George Floyd as Thomas Lane
Thomas Lane has hired a lawyer named
Earl Grey and I can tell you this guy is
not at all lemony and mild like Earl
Grey tea he's actually quite the
opposite and he imploded on live
television last night he was interviewed
by CNN's Chris Cuomo and Earl Grey tried
to suggest that if bystanders were
really so concerned with how George
Floyd was being manhandled by police why
didn't the bystanders jump in to
restrain the police he actually says
this and then he has no choice but to
back away from it when Chris Cuomo tells
him how bonkers it is what if all these
people say why why didn't my client
intercede well if the public is there
and there so enough more about this they
didn't intercede either in my clients
down where he can't really hold on hold
on counselor counselor hold on hold on
yes sir things once you're laying on a
man's legs you've got a fine view of
what's going on with that man the other
officer is literally a foot in front of
you on his neck
- I understand that he has a senior
officer telling him what to do but
there's also a duty to intervene
anythingit officer is doing something
that's dangerous to a civilian you have
a duty to intervene and he did not
intervene and the idea that the
civilians should have rushed in to a
policing situation in the inner city of
Minneapolis against four police officers
that have weapons and are kneeling on
the neck of a man don't you think that's
asking a little much of civilians and a
little too little of your client
absolutely I'm not I just brought that
up well what what you say is it went
away
you know he's got his feet he was
holding his feet down mr. King was
officer King was next and then shavon so
obviously the suggestion of civilians
intervening against armed police is
ridiculous and Earl Gray realized it and
has to back off and say well I'm merely
bringing it up could this guy possibly
be a good lawyer his defense of his
client Officer Thomas Lane
was to ask why didn't civilians commit a
crime because if civilians actually go
and try to interfere with for armed
officers in the process of restraining
and subsequently killing George Floyd
they would have been arrested and likely
charged with interfering with law
enforcement now this is a good
opportunity to step back and give you a
sense of in general how the other
officers meaning the ones that were not
George Derek shavon might approach their
defenses the idea is to say there was a
power dynamic these guys like Thomas
Lane who is represented by attorney err
Earl Grey they were following orders
they weren't really in a position
because of seniority differences to
disagree even if they wanted to now
here's our friend Josh Campbell Campbell
former FBI agent CNN reporter friend of
the David Pakman show
asking Earl Gray about is this the PAP
is the power dynamic thing what you were
going with and Earl Grey didn't like it
at all take a look were you kind of
applying a power dynamic between the
scenes I'm sure right but is here
essentially is your claim that he was
following orders your client so Earl
Grey getting very upset there with a
pretty straightforward question from
josh campbell and then again another
example this is Earl Grey explaining my
client couldn't really do anything I
mean he couldn't restrain Derrick shavon
take a look be unreasonable for my
client to go up and try and drag Shulman
off of
you've got a jerk up in the front and my
guys back there with four days shall we
roll him over and he says no won't wait
for the ambulance twice and then he says
he's suffering from a delirium I don't
know what what you're supposed to do as
a cop so that's the gist of at least how
Earl Grey will seek to defend Thomas
lanes actions in the killing of George
Floyd he was only on the job a few days
he didn't have the power dynamics on his
side he did suggest rolling George Floyd
over and he couldn't really physically
restrained Eric Shaw in any way which is
probably accurate he physically
restraining Derek shavon was not a
likely path so we've talked about many
reforms by the way but one that might
benefit police is to reorganize some of
these a sort of standards of the chain
of seniority there's a really
interesting story that Malcolm Gladwell
tells in his book outliers nearly twelve
years ago at this point about South
Korean pilots which explained that South
Korean culture precluded co-pilots from
pointing out to captain's hey I'm seeing
something that doesn't look right and
under that cultural norm South Korean
aviation was not particularly safe and
so South Korean Airlines retrained and
said listen the in the cockpit we have a
different protocol than in Korean
culture and first officers not only
should be allowed to but they should be
encouraged to point irregularities out
to captain's you won't be punished it's
the right thing to do and when they
reorganize that norm cultural norm in
this case South Korean aviation became
dramatically safer and much the same way
it is probably true that an officer on
duty for four days this is not a defense
of Thomas Lane but that one element is
true in police culture in the ranks
it would be seen as inappropriate or
unacceptable to question the tactics
the senior officer in that particular
case that needs to be changed and that
is totally separate from how any of
these individual charges are ultimately
going to play out let's take a quick
break my interview with Neil Ferguson is
next make sure you're following the
david pakman show on instagram at david
pakman show Donald Trump's press
secretary Kaley mcenany was asked at her
Monday press briefing by reporters
whether Donald Trump plans to resume the
coronavirus press briefings and she
didn't answer the question but the
answer is obviously no and it's a good
question to ask because we're seeing
massive coronavirus hot spots growing
very rapidly in the United States mostly
different areas than the early hot spots
and I'm going to talk about the virus
itself shortly but there's a real media
story here to understand we talked about
the bully pulpit of corporate media much
of what is in the national discussion
the top three stories that are in the
national discussion at any given time
are essentially led by corporate media
and this is called agenda setting power
it's not necessarily that corporate
media tells us what to think about any
particular issue although sometimes they
do but it's that corporate media tells
us what to think about what to talk
about and I'll give you an example
remember kids in cages the immigration
scandal it's still going on but it's
rarely if ever in the media except to
mentioned that some people being held at
the border have contracted coronavirus
but nothing has fundamentally changed
about that story which was wall-to-wall
coverage previously during this
administration now it's like it doesn't
exist then it was coronavirus we have a
pandemic daily press briefings including
Donald Trump and doctors pouchy and
Bert's daily updates down to the
specific details about the number of
masks and project air bridge flights
from Mike Pence and then the White House
signaled we're going to stop Trump
wondered aloud about injecting bleach
and isopropyl alcohol to treat
coronavirus it became clear that the
White House didn't really want more
visibility for doctors Burks and Foudy
talking about the virus so the briefing
stopped and
that over time as more and more states
have decided to reopen some are safely
reopening some are very unsafely
reopening the topic of the virus itself
started to take a backseat especially as
the George Floyd killing took place and
the massive protests started and now as
we're seeing the protests are starting
to die down a little bit but the big
topic has become defund the police or do
not defund the police depending on whose
perspective you're listening to
right-wing media saying defunding the
police would be anarchy some on the left
furious that Biden does not want to
defund the police but understand that
nothing materially has changed with
coronavirus we'll look at the data put
it up on the screen now fortunately as
you can see we've seen a leveling off
and a slow decline in the number of
cases at the national level but mostly
what we're seeing is the cases being
relocated where we are finding new hot
spots understand that at the peak we
were finding 25 to 30,000 cases a day we
are still finding 19 to 25 thousand new
cases every single day and the number of
active cases meaning people who
currently have the virus is still as
high as it's ever been and yet Donald
Trump barely talks about coronavirus his
press secretary barely talks about
coronavirus right-wing media is done
with it other than calling it a scam or
a conspiracy and even corporate media is
increasingly talking about coronavirus
less and less but we have a new
political article that points out not
only is the pandemic still very much a
pandemic with no effective treatment no
vaccine we have new hotspots that are
setting records for new cases there are
parts of the country that are exploding
with virus cases and Donald Trump is
just silent another massive failure
because Trump by not talking about it
makes people think the threat is over
meaning they go out and behavior
responsibly and cause even more cases
and in fact as we talked about yesterday
on the bonus show Donald Trump is
planning to restart his huge mega alleys
as part
his 20/20 re-election campaign in a
couple of weeks so I'll give you some
really specific examples Texas which
started to reopen pretty quickly
is exploding week to week they have more
and more cases the number of active
cases in Texas is higher today than it
has ever been
Florida run by Republican governor Ron
de santis also started to open pretty
early they were caught lying about
numbers as we previously covered and
after a small dip sometime in April
which might have just been them lying
they once again in Florida are seeing
record numbers of new cases now I
mentioned that the cases are
dramatically shifting from some parts of
the country to others this doesn't mean
you know Kings aren't going terribly
everywhere I am thrilled to say that
here in Massachusetts at least for now
cases have been very steadily declining
since late April the graph I'm showing
you you'll see a one-day spike about a
week ago that's not really a spike that
that was a bunch of presumptive cases
from the three months of coronavirus
were all added in on that day but we are
looking really good here and I'm
thrilled to see that so this is a story
not just about the virus itself which is
still raging with no treatment or
vaccine but it's a media story as well
about the agenda-setting power that
corporate media has we said six save
seven weeks ago Trump's strategy is
going to be just start pretending it
doesn't exist start talking about the
economy jobs reopening and a bunch of
corporate media has played along now in
the meantime things are so bad here in
the United States with coronavirus that
as more and more countries or reopening
travel the United States is being banned
I'll give you an example Iceland has so
dominated the virus that Iceland decided
that on I believe it's June 15th they're
going to reopen tourism when you get to
Iceland you have to have a kovat test at
the airport or quarantine for 14 days
people are going to be able to go to
Iceland and start doing tourism if
that's what they want to do except
Americans aren't going to be allowed
because things are so out of control
here other countries people are going to
be allowed to start going to Iceland not
Americans because it's a disaster and I
wouldn't be surprised if this continues
as the virus
keeps spreading in different US states
other countries are going to be
increasingly controlling it not Brazil
India you know there's places that are
that Russia that aren't controlling it
but more and more countries are going to
be allowed to restart travel and
Americans are going to be banned from
going to other countries because it is
so poorly handled here now as far as the
framing and the propaganda expect Trump
soon to start arguing that an Tifa and
other left-wing protesters are
responsible for spreading the virus if
the numbers keep growing in a lot of
these new hotspots like Florida and
Texas I would anticipate that Donald
Trump will take the protests as the
perfect opportunity to say it's an Tifa
and lefties that are now responsible if
he even mentions it at all and to be
clear the protests will cause some
number of new cases what we're seeing
now is reflective of the situation 10 to
14 days ago and that's important to
remember be ready for it because it's
going to happen and don't forget we're
still in the middle of a pandemic which
some doctors believe is still in its
beginning phases which is overwhelming
to think about if you want to see a
tragic preview really of the voter
suppression and catastrophic
disenfranchisement that we're going to
see in the November election look no
further than yesterday in Georgia
Georgia among some other states had
primary elections yesterday and you may
or may not even have heard that
elections were going on in local
elections depending on what media
sources you consume you may not even
have been aware that there were problems
or that there were even elections
yesterday but there were and this is
really it's really a crisis level
situation where the United States looks
much more like the developing countries
that are right-wing leaders often
criticize based on what our elections
looked like yesterday we had people
waiting in lines hours and hours long
outdoors in the heat often wearing masks
because we are still by the way dealing
with the corona virus pandemic of course
this was there were shortages of ballots
and this was all disproportion
in the minority precincts parts of the
state of Georgia where the population is
majority minority places that tend on
average to vote more for Democrats than
they tend to vote for Republicans and at
some point I mean how many times are we
going to see the exact same story and
the answer is probably many sadly but
we've been watching this for election
cycle after election cycle this happened
back in Georgia back in 2018 in Georgia
that was when secretin Secretary of
State Brian Kemp a Republican was
running for governor and as Secretary of
State he oversaw his own election
against Stacey Abrams to be governor of
Georgia ultimately one big surprise and
widespread allegations of the exact same
type of voter suppression
disenfranchisement reduction of polling
places in disproportionately minority
and democratic-leaning areas it's the
same game and the reason that
Republicans are going to aggressively
push this in Georgia is that Georgia is
increasingly a contested state now I
don't want to you know pretend like it's
a battleground state in any real sense
right now presidentially for now it's
still a state that trump is likely going
to win modestly easily he's up in the
polls about 7 points right now in
Georgia he'll almost certainly win but
the point is Georgia in local and state
elections is increasingly purple it's
close enough for Trump that he's going
to have to spend some money there which
is money he can't spend in two places
he's going to spend it there instead of
somewhere else back in 2016 Donald Trump
only one Georgia by five percentage
points in the 2012 election Mitt Romney
had defeated Barack Obama by 8 in
Georgia and again it's the state and
local races are maybe suggestive of what
we might see in the future in Georgia
which is more of a centrist lean than a
hard right lean and Republicans are
understandably very worried so we we saw
a preview yesterday in Georgia of what
we're going to see in a ton of places in
the fall this includes Florida Ohio
Wisconsin
really
it's like every contested battleground
state that was important to Trump in
2016 that he can't really afford to lose
without putting his re-election at risk
we are going to see this exact same
thing now of course lots of Georgia
voters you'll be glad to know had no
problem at all voting yesterday its
voters who disproportionately vote in
overwhelmingly white precincts and they
were widely reporting listen I showed up
and voted in five minutes there was no
line what are people complaining about
and that's exactly the strategy make it
really easy for voters that are
statistically more likely to vote
Republican to vote make it much more
difficult for voters that at the
aggregate you know broad mathematical
level are more likely to vote for
Democrats and it's the same betrayal of
Georgia voters once again this is
election rigging we have to stop using
these softer terms like there were
reports of isolated irregularities come
on there were delays voting in some
precincts those are essentially
gaslighting terms this is rigging
because it's intentional it's calculated
it's an effort to swing results by
controlling and manipulating and sort of
molding who gets to vote easily versus
who's going to have trouble voting so a
few things have to happen first we need
as many nonprofit groups as possible to
be armed and ready to fight every voter
suppression attempt when they try to
reduce polling places cut early voting
hours put stricter guidelines for
requesting an absentee ballot purge
voter rolls as we've seen done in a
number of different states
we need these nonprofit groups suing
every single time and gumming up any of
these attempts as much as possible
that's number one number two
anybody who can either vote early or
vote absentee should plan to vote early
an or vote absentee and should
understand what the process looks like
now in some places you will have access
to both an absentee ballot vote by mail
oh and early voting you you will have
your choice of the two
some places it's one or the other
depending on the absentee ballot rules
or the early voting rules so inform
yourself about what is going on where
you vote the absentee ballot you request
from the state ahead of time some states
are saying because of coronavirus
they'll send everybody an application
for an absentee ballot others are
looking at sending the ballots
themselves but the point is the normal
processes you request a ballot you get
it you fill it out you mail it in that's
it you're done okay
early voting is in-person voting
depending on the state sometimes about
three weeks before the election day in
this case November 3rd early voting will
start it's usually limited locations
like here in Boston if I want to vote
early I can't vote in my neighborhood I
have to go to one of I think it's like
five or six locations including City
Hall all the way downtown find out where
that is as many people as possible
should take advantage of whichever
method is available in their state and
whatever is easier for you now one last
thing the Georgia Secretary of State
says there's going to be an
investigation into what happened
yesterday now I really want you to
understand how absurd this is Brian Kemp
was Secretary of State in November of
2018 and he ran the election in which he
was a candidate for governor and lo and
behold he won amidst allegations of
voter suppression
now another Secretary of State is going
to investigate voter suppression that he
presided over to help his own party it's
a joke we are a joke it's I got a bunch
of emails yesterday and today from
European viewers saying what's going on
in the US with your voting system how is
this still a problem in one of the
richest countries in the world and the
answer is it's a problem by design we
could solve this but there isn't a
problem if you ask the people that
benefit from this voter suppression
there are now calls it's just
unbelievable there are calls for the
u.s. to bring in United Nations
elections observers in November to try
to ensure that there are fair elections
in the United States this is how
unreliable and pathetic our election
system is and we're gonna see a lot more
of it as we get a closer and closer to
November